hello and welcome to this video
playing black against fsm 666 fsm
okay so um play them before
no no particular
memory of this game memory of this game
weird english anyway so let's see i'm
playing
this um kind of pseudo
banco with b5 i'm not sure if that is
the right term
[Music]
probably not so
e6 i'm kind of lost here
i mean not the position is not lost i'm
just saying
i cannot remember how this is played in
any way
it's been a while since i analyzed that
so not sure i could have
actually taken on d5 immediately
yeah okay let's do it now
bishop b7 how does he actually keep that
pawn
it's going d6 i guess okay so let's stop
[Music]
that
yeah in many cases
actually e4 is a move in such a
situation because black has
problems taking it i'm not really sure
about this particular one maybe that was
not on
so what am i doing here i probably want
to put more pressure on that pawn
it's got the check i have knight bd7
then
okay i will start with this
put more pressure on the pawn um
one question here is if i should go g6
bishop g7 or
not i think bishop e7 is
better here okay but here i have queen
c7 right
i really don't mind that like takes
takes how does he cover
e4
maybe with pawn e4 actually because i
take queen e2 but then i can actually
take um
d5 knight f to d2 that's a tough one
probably not possible
and now what what about now
the thing is if i don't take and he gets
knight d2 c4 my position is
probably very questionable so it's
kind of this is very tempting to take
very tempting he still has reasonable
compensation i feel
me yeah well d5 is basically a goner as
well
if he doesn't have anything great okay
this is putting the knight
right into a fork
g5 knight f5
takes it
then f3 may be coming
knight f5 is definitely a dangerous move
hmm
i'm generally scared about things like
that
i can actually castle queenside in this
position
that's something that i should keep in
mind so let's do this
it's going to go knight f5 i don't
really see anything else
i'll take now what
yes but here i can take d5
queen takes queen takes at the
anti-scotch rook takes e4
king d7
take take take take okay
didn't see that move i don't know if
it's good though
really so knight f6 is going
ei then he is good if that then is going
e5
so i have to go somewhere else like here
increment chess very important
otherwise i would be just completely
toast
because of the time situation
and now d5 s95 i can take king d6 and
the ending is uh
excellent excellent i'm just
up how many pawns two pawns
and he's got rebecca he cannot go
anywhere reasonable
should be a complete win
yeah there's no way to escape here
really
[Music]
knight d2 i take b2 and knight a5 is
kind of
heading nowhere right so that was a
shaky game
probably
um yeah maybe i can take here on d5
already
and then i get this d6 it's similar to
the to the game i played h6
wow the engine goes to g5 here well
i mean this is probably not bad yeah
e3 is kind of smallish i thought that
maybe e5 is actually possible sorry e4
is actually possible
because that feels really dangerous like
a check here
and castles oops and castles it seems to
be dangerous the engine is just 0.4 on
that
low um depth but
it's very dangerous the whole opening is
a bit
risky of course bishop b7
he checked me
and then this
okay ah well that is a really really
uh clear improvement on my game
i can take and just grab this
yeah this is really strong actually
because i mean
it's got nowhere near compensation
the the reason here is that the night is
just totally awful
it cannot be improved yeah
like here are weaknesses but he doesn't
get there
okay okay queen c7 was not
as convincing and now he played e4
yeah and i didn't really dare to take it
i actually i'm a little bit surprised
this
this i saw this line
and thought that cannot be played
yeah you know this is very very cool
for rookie 8
like knight takes rookie 8
i know g5 first g5 first
i mean this is not a realistic line yeah
in a in a human blitz game between
like non-geniuses but uh
it's a it's a funny funny line just to
see that it works
so this was possible and also g5 here
like this and then castling yeah because
this is hanging and there's rookie 8 and
f5
completely completely nuts
and f5 seems to be a possibility as well
you know what i absolutely did not
realize that i can castle queenside i'm
just too dogmatic a player
i mean like like this okay
g5 even works but you know i can go here
yeah
so i could have taken that but i didn't
didn't realize
and now i took it and it it is dangerous
for sure queen d3
maybe queen d3 yeah
queen d3 is actually a simple and good
move
hmm
yeah maybe i have to do this i actually
didn't see that line at all
this is interesting like
this could be um some sort of
compensation
i've got two pawns and white's
coordination is a little bit off
okay he went with this and i went g5
and this is not a good move knight f5
takes it i mean it seems to be
playable but it's it's not like super
great
so queen takes d5 seems to be better but
i took it
and now f3 f3 should win for me
queen takes queen takes knight takes
pawn
takes 93 so actually the game yeah
that's true the game was winning so this
is um
the consequence of this line okay okay
okay i see
so that was a tough game this line here
is always
um leading to complicated positions
and it's a it's slightly risky i have
that in my older
banker repertoire for black on chesapeal
but it's it's a risky
it's a risky line to play alright
guys thanks for watching